I'll admit it is a bit arbitrary to do
this but you'll see why and we do it in
a few moments this this is I can kind of
imagine it as the corner of a rectangle
the corner directly right then I can
begin a whole bunch of other ways right
how else could I get there well one
other popular scheme is to imagine said
as a point on the circumference of a
circle okay and the reason why we like
circles is because there's lots of fancy
mats and symmetry that comes from
circles that we can take advantage of
right so what I want you to do is try
your best if you put yours in bed right
the circle that passes through Sam with
a center on the origin part of it will
look something like this I guess okay so
yeah the idea so we're trying to picture
Z being on the circumference the only
thing about being on the circumference
is that I can find a wide angle triangle
over there and sort of think this like
the unit circle I don't know how big the
circle is so it'll have some kind of
radius but if you had another color
there I'm going to put in this
construction which I hope you remember
back from when you first met the unit
circle right and connected into tree
remembering that this is of X units to
the right and y units top okay that
means X is here and Y is over here yeah
so if I want to think about this like we
introduced this parameter on the unit
circle right what parameter do we
introduce we introduce the angle to sent
up together with a radius right so you
need a radius to know how far to go away
and then you need an angle to know how
far should you turn to get to that spot
okay now I can get to this are in this
data through what these guys are and
using just a little bit of simple trick
right just think back to unit circle
star if I say for instance cos theta
just in this simple right angle triangle
here cos theta is adjacent on hypotenuse
do you agree with that X
all right so I can say that X over that
the real pot is aa cause okay and the
same triangle I can use the other ratio
juice what's me sign
I can say sign theater is why not right
what kind of sick to death from
projectile motion when you're thinking
about okay which ratio gives me the
matching it sides that I want so you can
see from here I can say that Y is aa
saying they don't and so now they don't
X&Y are I can use this to rewrite
rectangular form right I'm just going to
substitute australium instead of saying
Z equals x plus iy I'm just gonna put in
these R and theta terms in their places
right so this is aa because you know the
front and I times ah thank you okay so
all I've done is just a substitution but
now I'm not thinking in terms of
horizontal vertical components
components and think about how far away
and what angle should I turn okay I can
also pull out a common factor here right
namely the radius and just like this guy
has a name rectangular form this one
also has a name maybe I should write
these down okay this is very long
this guy over here is what we call polar
form because it's kind of like picturing
you know the origin is kind of like the
North Pole right that's where you start
and everything else kind of gets
measured relatives that tell me how far
away you should be and tell me what
angle you'd like Minturn okay all right
so here are two different ways of
writing and just like these guys each of
them fits a different kind of problem
okay all right
next attention one students you've been
feeling okay this is tricky it's a bit
weird
you're now on the same pose the
extensions to students because I'm about
to show them stuff they've never seen
before
okay so this is everything you need to
know in extension to just a simple idea
the manipulation of this stuff required
just the fact that I can write these in
different forms all right you're going
to write a new sub here in a second I
want to tell you what it is yes show you
some pictures you don't need to draw
these or anything like that um I want
you to think back because of um I just I
just covered it because of the fact that
I just introduced trig right like close
is inside all that kind of thing I want
to think of this a little more so I'm
I'm taking all the way back to your to I
want to walk you back through the
journey of learning trip like all about
from like you know it is when you first
met sign wasn't here right what was i
conjure to you as he unites do know
reaches it was socket all right so you
first met writing the triangles and you
said okay for reasons that are
inscrutable to you let's name these
sides and label them and then let's just
listen compare them to each other okay
so you learned your socket talk very
faithfully and that's what treat wants
to you okay but then you learn actually
it doesn't just work in right angle
triangles if you have an on right angle
triangle if you just do a little bit of
finagling and construction you can find
some right angle triangles in there and
then you can use we introduced the sine
or cosine wrong area of your triangle
and they apply to all trial not just the
ones with right angles because you can
find right angles in there right and
then you kept going remember where did
you go from here
very good
you make a good math teacher ah we went
from writing with triangles to not
writing the triangles and then we said
well maybe we want angles that not even
in triangles at all like you're never
gonna find you know 225 degrees in a
triangle right but can we understand how
sine and cos and tan work with that and
so we said well if you have a circle so
who's got all the angles in it and just
like just like this right it doesn't
matter these big things not a right
angle triangle if I can find right angle
triangles in it and so that's what we
did with the unit circle we found the
right angle triangle just like we did
which a few minutes ago and so that's
what we came up with this definition and
then your trigonometry work exploded
because we stopped talking about
triangles really we started saying yeah
how they look at like what does it look
like in fact this is where you know the
tree gave wings to get all their names
right it's called sine cosine means cut
all right like the sinus in your nose is
the curved part of your nasal passage
and so this is the sine curve right and
we said okay let's think of that sign
cause it has functions it's not worried
about the triangles anymore let's think
about about them and then we
differentiate them and they become a
whole new sort of ideas you sort of left
the triangles behind and then we said
they're not just cool on their own you
can use them in all kinds of
applications right we said get you know
what lots of things in the world they go
up and down just like the sine and
cosine codes right
so we said simple hum like motion right
I would just bring in a simple acidified
example and then we said actually nobody
even things that don't go just up and
down predictably like this there are
other things in the world where silent
codes can be useful like you know when
you throw something through the air
right so we use lots of sines and
cosines in resolving what was happy here
horizontal vertical blah blah and so
trigonometry seems sort of less good of
triangles behind by the way we never
have really the triangles are still
there they're still hiding right it's
just that we have learned through
calculus to be able to say well actually
all of these triangles are even they're
testily smaller no I know with that I
still work with them I can still model
them through tangents and so on okay so
I want to take this same idea of how you
started it
I don't need this anymore you started
thinking about trig just in right angled
triangles right but I want to move past
that we want to move to sort of
retrievers functions and how we can
understand because that's super useful
you saw all the applications we got out
of that right